should we take it from what you've said  then that you're now calling on Penny  Morton to do the same and step aside  well look that's up to  something I know it's up to her but what  do you think should she do it or not  yeah well I was going to I was going to  say what I do know is that Rishi enjoys  the support of a large number of uh  conservative MPS and there's a very high  nomination threshold of a hundred so  um you know  putting it the other way around really  she doesn't think that it's in the bag  he's speaking to colleagues this morning  he's working very hard to attract those  supporters who were perhaps with Boris  Johnson uh previously but I mean look  I'll leave it to Penny she's a terrific  colleague